un petit tour dans les étoiles pour
terminer le moteur de recherche google
lance un nouveau service sur internet
ils proposent désormais des images
fournies notamment par le télescope
spatial hubble
si mon corps me dit on connaissait
google earth la possibilité de survoler
n'importe quel endroit de la terre
voici google sky le ciel à portée de
main ou plutôt de souris explorez le
firmament depuis son ordinateur est
désormais chose possible pour les
astronomes en herbe
le géant de l'internet google a mis hier
en ligne une toute nouvelle version de
son logiciel gratuit
ici ce n'est plus notre planète bleue
qui est minutieusement scruté mais
l'univers andromède cassiopée ou encore
plus simplement la lune
à vous de naviguer parmi quelques 100
millions des toiles et 200 millions de
galaxy pour réaliser cette carte
virtuelle du ciel le plus célèbre des
moteurs de recherche a réalisé un
véritable patchwork d'image puisant dans
les fonds de plusieurs instituts
astronomique 125 images haute définition
ont également été prises par le
télescope spatial hubble
un bon moyen malgré la météo capricieuse
du moment de plonger sa tête dans les
étoiles